[Music]
speaking of messages
of feminism of anti-misogyny
anti-patriarchy
did you feel that those messages were in
the original plans or script for borat
too or was that something you brought to
it was that a
conversation you had with sasha how did
you contribute to that
i think that has been from the beginning
of the
moment when they've been creating the
script because
the whole team that we've been working
on uh i can call every single
down every single one of them uh by
their names and i can
stand behind my uh words that i feel
them like family and they are all
people that are inspiring that are there
to stand up against misogyny and stand
up against
uh women being subjugated by the
patriarchy because unfortunately
it's crazy but we are living in 2021
and there are still places around the
world there are still
people that are believing that women are
like
somehow um i don't know and
not equal which is crazy so i believe
that that has been one of
the messages in the movie sasha probably
has a better answer but from the first
script that i read
it is was there it was there and sasha
actually
this is one story that i haven't
mentioned it sasha uh sasha
uh to tell at some point was about to
become like extremely
pro-lgbtq activist feminist
that was the reason why i cut my hair
but their covet happened
they were thinking even more the script
was evolving
every single day and we left that line
so it is being there from the very first
time